WALLS, SECURITY SYSTEMS, THEY'VE
GOT A LOT, ESPECIALLY THE RICH
ONES.
NICE WALLS.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP REOPENED
THE GOVERNMENT, HE ALSO CALLED
FOR BY PERSON, NEED TO ATTEMPT
TO HASH OUT SOME BORDER
COMPROMISE.
JOHN WAS TALKING ABOUT A PAPER
FOR FEBRUARY 16.
WHY HAVEN'T WE HEARD ABOUT ANY
PROGRESS?
HERE NOW REMEMBER THAT TEAM, TOM
GRAVES OF GEORGIA.
CONGRESSMAN, ANY PROGRESS
WHATSOEVER AND IT'S NOT -- DON'T
BE PARTISAN ABOUT THIS.
WE'LL CAN WE DO NOW TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS BEFORE THE 16TH.
>> NOT BEING PARTISAN AT ALL,
THERE'S BEEN ZERO PROGRESS.
WE'VE HAD ONE MEETING SINCE HIS
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WAS CREATED
AND IT WAS CREATED BY
NANCY PELOSI.
YOU REMEMBER SHE SAID OPEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND WILL NEGOTIATE.
SHE CREATED THIS COMMITTEE.
SHE CONTROLS THIS COMMITTEE.
HER CHAIRMEN CHAIRS THIS
COMMITTEE.
SHE HAS MORE VOTES THAN ANYONE
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
WE'VE HAD ONE MEETING.
I HAVE REQUESTED MORE.
I'VE STAYED ALL LAST WEEK, WENT
THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
YET NO MORE MEETINGS.
>> Laura: WELL, HENRY CUELLAR,
SAID THIS ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
ABOUT THE WALL.
>> FIRST ABOUT WERE NOT GOING TO
HAVE A WALL.
CAN WE LOOK AT SOME SORT OF
ENHANCED BARRIER?
THAT IS SOMETHING WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY LIVING ON THE
BORDER, YOU HAVE TO LET THE
LOCAL BORDER PATROL CHIEF HAVE
THE SAY SO AND LET THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY THE INVOLVED SO THEY
CAN COME UP WITH MAY BE SOME
SORT OF ENHANCED BARRIER.
>> Laura: OKAY, WHAT DOES THIS
LOOK LIKE?
I'M A BIT CONFUSED.
ENHANCED BARRIER.
NOT A WALL.
SEE THROUGH IT.
I THINK A WHILE YOU CAN SEE
THROUGH BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
IT SEE-THROUGH.
IT'S KIND OF ALREADY AND
ENHANCED BARRIER.
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A SEMANTIC
PROBLEM IN PART, CORRECT?
>> WELL, IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
PLAY ON WORDS.
ENHANCED BARRIER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IS TAKING AN OLD WALL
AND IMPROVING IT.
IT'S NO NEW WALL.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS NEW WALLS,
WHICH I AGREE WITH.
ENHANCED BARRIERS, ONE PIECE.
>> Laura: WELL, WHEN YOU SEE
THE VIDEO JUST RELEASED LAST
WEEK AND THE WEEK BEFORE OF
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AT ONE TIME
CRAWLING ACROSS AN AREA THAT, I
MEAN, MY 10-YEAR-OLD COULD CRAWL
OVER IT.
IT'S NOT A DIFFICULT BARRIER.
IN SOME PLACES YOU JUST WALK
ACROSS THE DESERT, VERY
DANGEROUS PARTS.
YOU AREN'T A COUNTRYMEN THAT'S
HOW YOU GET INTO YOUR COUNTRY IN
A PLACE WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO COME IN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT A COUNTRY DOES.
I MEAN, IF YOU WANT TO STAND
COUNTRY, AT LEAST.
>> RIGHT, A LOT OF AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PLAN
THAT WAS PRESENTED BY HOMELAND
SECURITY, I MEAN, THEY CLEARLY
SEE THERE NEEDS TO BE NEW,
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS, STEEL
BARRIERS, WALLS.
IN ADDITION TO ENHANCEMENTS, IN
ADDITION TO TECHNOLOGY, BORDER
PATROL, ADDITIONAL JUDGES AND
SUCH.
THERE IS A LOT TO DO, BUT A WALL
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF IT.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THEY ARE
WALKING AWAY FROM IT.
>> Laura: WELL, WHAT THEY WILL
SALES WERE GOING TO DO DRONES
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIG
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BII
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIT
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIO
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIU
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIT
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIO
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIS
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIA
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIE
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIH
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIP
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIY
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIA
AND SENSORS AND A LOT OF THE BIT
PORTS OF ENTRY.
THEY ARE HANGING A LOT OF IT ON
THE PORTS OF ENTRY WHETHER
MAKING SOME PROGRESS.
LOWER NUMBER OF APPREHENSION.
ANYTIME YOU BRING IT UP, WHILE,